all right hi everybody thanks for
coming to the session i am aaron parecki
uh senior security architect at octa and
um as
uh as like i said i'm also involved in
the wealth working group where i help
write and contribute to the specs
and uh maintain the website oauth.net
which is the community home of oauth so
i am just steeped in this world all day
and it's a lot of fun to talk about so
the plan for
for this session is i'm going to
share an update about sort of where
things are
in the oauth world and talk about a
little bit of of background so we have
some context but then
uh talk about the the best
current way to do
things in oauth as well as talk about
some of what's happening in the future
and what you can expect to see
coming up in the uh
in the in that world
so before we get into
oauth itself i want to set up some of
the context around why we actually have
oauth
and
the this really came from the uh
the past where we were very used to the
idea of password-based
authentication
and that would be something like you
would enter a username and password into
an application
and then it would send it over to the
api and the api would validate the
password by probably looking it up in a
database for example
and then it would return data or you
would be logged in
and this of course has a number of
problems because especially if you're
storing passwords in plain text which
thankfully is not something that is very
common anymore
and instead what is a lot more common is
storing instead of the password itself
storing a hash of the password
and this solves the problem on one end
of of not uh where it's not a good idea
to you know store passwords in plain
text
however this doesn't actually solve the
problem on the other end
that problem being
users are still entering passwords into
applications so you may see
screens like this as you're using your
your
various apps on your phone
and this is a
you know pretty common thing and for a
simple application that maybe has just
one native app and talking to one api
this probably does actually work fine
however you start to very quickly run
into limitations with this for example
when you want to add multi-factor
authentication because now all of a
sudden you're building in multi-factor
auth into your app and there's of course
many ways to do that
and that could be anything from the from
sms code
to a google authenticator code or push
based two-factor auth
and
where this starts to really become a
problem is if you are having if you are
building more than one app because as
soon as you're building more than one
app now you're having to recreate
multi-factor auth in every native app
interface
and that can just add a lot of time to
your development and a lot of it just
slows things down when you're building
that out
there's yet one more problem with
passwords with handling passwords in
applications which is a lot harder to
solve because it's more about
teaching users about best practices
we we know that as
as someone who signs up for accounts and
creates passwords we're not supposed to
be reusing passwords right but
a lot of people do because it's easier
than making unique passwords for
everything and figuring out some scheme
to maintain that
so the problem is that
if you have multiple applications where
you are logging into things
and you're being asked for your password
in all of those applications how do you
know the next time you see a pop-up
asking for your password that it's
really the real
service asking for your password and not
something trying to steal your password
ironically one of the worst examples of
this is apple
where pay attention next time you're
using your computer or your phone
to how many different times and how many
different ways you get asked for your
mac os password as well as your icloud
password
this is just a screenshot uh screenshots
i was able to take very quickly by just
going into various screens in my in my
computer
and you can see that each one of these
looks different even though they uh do
they they're the same account well two
of them are my mac password and two of
them are my icloud password so if i've
ever presented one with one of these
dialogues in the future
what how do i as a user understand that
it really is apple asking for my
password not something trying to steal
my password
this is a screenshot from this great
blog post that demonstrates this on
mobile
where
the
screenshot on the left is the actual
itunes or ios pop-up asking for your
itunes password or your icloud password
they also call it five different things
and on the right is a game that this
developer built and popped up uh it the
game pops up this
dialogue asking for your itunes password
your apple id
again these dialogues look exactly the
same so as a user how are you supposed
to know which one is safe to enter your
password into and
that's just not something that is easy
to communicate to users when you're in
this situation of showing password
dialogues that look different all the
time
and then
these are these are examples of why
passwords are a problem for first party
apps but it gets to be even bigger
problem when we're talking about
third-party applications
so this used to be a very common pattern
on the internet where a an app like yelp
would launch
and it would go and say hey let's see if
your friends are already using the app
and it would want to get access to your
google contacts in your email
so to do that it would ask you for your
email address and the password
to your email
and then it was gonna then it goes and
logs in to your email and download your
address book
and uh then it can find your friends and
this of course is not safe under any
circumstances but it was very common at
the time
notice it says
this is from facebook right and notice
that it says facebook will not store
your password well as a user you just
kind of have to trust that there's no
way to guarantee that
and
the other thing you're trusting is that
it's going to only access your contacts
even though you're giving it your gmail
account and it could access any data in
gmail
so all of these problems are are really
what are motivating the the creation of
oauth
in this third party app use case we
would like to find a solution that lets
third-party apps like yelp get access to
the data that they want in order to do
whatever function they are promising to
the user while preventing access to
other parts of the account that they
don't need access to
so that's really the problem statement
that oauth was created to solve which is
how do we let apps access data without
sharing passwords and this applies to
both first party apps as well as
third-party apps in the third-party app
use case obviously it means that the the
third party app doesn't ever need to
touch the user's password which is great
for security and in the first party app
use case it also means we can better
integrate multi-factor auth and also
avoid having to
give users complicated rules about how
to identify phishing attacks
so
that's kind of the the
origins of oauth and how that was
originally created
so
oauth it turns out is not a single spec
oauth is actually a collection of
several several specs and the way this
is uh set up is these are all kind of
think of them as like building blocks
where they all provide
a each of these specs provides a
specific feature and you can stack them
all up to build a complete system so
this core document rfc 6749 is the
original core oauth2 spec and this
defines a few what are called grant
types that talk about different ways
that an application can get access to to
data in an api
the thing that is not defined in the
core spec is for example
what that access actually looks like
and in practice the most common way that
access is represented is with what we
now know as a bearer token
and a bearer token is the idea that if
you are holding on to the token you can
access that data so think of it as the
same way as you would a hotel key card
where you go to the hotel you check in
they give you this key card which gives
you access to
various rooms in the hotel that key card
does not necessarily represent you as a
person it represents that you
can access certain resources in the
hotel
so that is actually documented in a
separate rfc the idea of a barrier token
where if you are
in possession of this token you can use
it
so that rfc talks about uh various ways
to use the token for example in an http
header or in a form post body or in a
query string
so
okay
that's that's the foundation and then we
get into
some of the different recommendations
that have popped up over the years
around specific kinds of applications
when oauth was first created mobile
platforms were very very new and single
page apps
were also very new and haven't really
taken off yet as a as a normal pattern
on the internet so what that meant was
that
there were uh some sort of workarounds i
guess or or things in the course back
that
were um
were there because of the limitations in
these early platforms
primarily
the idea of
of using what we call the front channel
to send the access token to the app so
in
the
implicit flow
what happens is the os server sends the
access token back to the app through the
user's browser and the fact that it's
going through the user's browser is is
makes it
rely on the front channel and i like to
think of sending data to via the front
channel as putting it in an envelope
and
mailing it to somebody and then you kind
of just have to hope it gets there the
problem is that
if you've put it in an envelope and
shipped it in the mail you no longer can
actually be sure that it got there or
that it wasn't stolen or copied along
the way and similarly on the receiving
end you can't actually know if it's from
who you think it is
so if we are if we're ever using the
front channel in oauth we have to be
able to account for that and
compensate for the fact that we lose
that visibility on both sides of the
transaction
and that is what
the pixie extension is for so pixi yet
another rfc
adds in
security some security features around
the use of the front channel to make it
actually safe to send data in the front
channel and in in
in practice this also means that
instead of relying on the implicit flow
we can now use the authorization code
flow and protect that the authorization
codes use of the front channel with pixi
so
over the years we then ended up with
another rfc recommending making specific
recommendations for mobile apps as well
as for browser-based apps
and
um
thankfully
the the browser world has evolved over
time and we no longer really have to
support things that are lacking a lot of
the modern features like ie9 and safari
5. primarily cross-origin resource
sharing which is a key component to be
able to use the authorization code flow
now that cores is widely accessible and
widely available in browsers it's not
really a problem anymore which basically
means the implicit flow isn't needed
there the implicit flow was a workaround
for the lack of cross-origin resource
sharing support so it's not really
needed anymore
so
uh one of the things one of the other
documents in the in the that's being
worked on in the group is the security
best current practice which is
a document that is encapsulating all of
the best practices of how to do oauth
securely today
and things that it is recommending are
not using the implicit flow not using
the password flow and
um using pixie for everything instead
and avoiding use of
access tokens in query strings
so by now you're probably thinking okay
this is a big maze of specs and how do i
know
how to do this well
that is
one of the uh core efforts that that i
am working on in the group which is to
consolidate
all of this sort of mess of the last 10
years of specs into something that's a
lot simpler to read which is oauth 2.1
so if you look at the oauth 2.1 spec
you'll find that it actually uh
describes a much simpler version of all
of the
past documents
and
the goal here is to really consolidate
things capture the best practices
oauth 2.1 is not meant to be something
that's new or or adding new features
it's really meant to be a consolidation
and uh simplification of
the of the existing specs and of the
best practice today
so the links for for that draft
oauth.net 2.1 will give you a link out
to all the related documents as well
so that's the
uh that's the current the current state
of the core sort of what we call the
core of oauth i also want to talk about
some of the in progress work that is
nearing completion or is or was recently
completed to talk about some of the
different ways that work is evolving as
well
so there's three i want to call out
specifically three drafts the first one
is json web token profile for access
token which is now pending its rfc
number it's very very close to being
finalized there's uh d-pop which is a
proof-of-possession technique as well as
http signatures which is also a proof of
possession technique which i'll talk
more about what that means in a second
but json web token profile for access
tokens it's a long name but
basically what this spec is doing is
this is saying
if you're going to implement access
tokens as a json web token then here are
things to keep in mind and here's the
best way to do it
access tokens by no means have to be
json web tokens you can use for example
just a random string as an access token
and it will work fine but if you want to
use json web tokens to provide you all
the benefits those do have here's how to
do it and the json web token access
token will
contain certain claims
with a list of certain ways to validate
those claims and
that's what's captured in that spec
another uh
high
highly in
influx or in progress and uh topic is
this idea of sender constrained access
tokens so what i want to what i want to
get at here is that
the there is an underlying problem with
bearer tokens which was actually the
reason that it was split out into a new
rfc way at the beginning of oauth which
is that if you can steal one you can use
it and again think of the hotel card key
example if you find a hotel key on the
floor you can pick it up and you can try
it on a door and it might work and it
might let you in
even though that key card was not issued
to you
so the solution to this is to require
some sort of authentication of the
client instance of the software that's
actually using the access token
before it can actually use the access
token
and
the some sort of and the client instance
are the things that are
being worked out and and need to
sort of be
teased out until there's like a good
solution for it there are several
techniques for solving this problem that
are
documented
today and and uh in various
states there's mutual tls which is an
rfc
there is also a handful of individual
drafts some of them are adopted by the
working group as well
we don't have time to go through all the
details of all of these but i will say
that the top three here are the ones
that are the most either mature or i
think have the most potential for being
uh for being
the ones that end up being uh final
depop is uh
deep
http signatures are
them are similar to each other depop is
the idea of creating a signature about
the request and putting it in an http
header http signatures does as well but
it does it a different way and they have
a couple of different trade-offs so it
is worth looking into the details of
these if you're curious but again both
of these are very much in progress
they're not stable extensions yet
there's a couple of other really fun
extensions happening that are adding
features not necessarily just adding
security so for example rich
authorization requests is one that is
meant to be able to describe
uh requests that an application is
making beyond what you can describe with
scopes so you might have seen screens
like this where it says the app is
trying to access your contacts but what
if you had a screen like this that said
this app is trying to pay this merchant
by name this dollar amount from this
bank account well you can't describe
that in scopes so instead what rich
authorization request is doing is
providing a framework for describing
these kinds of
rich authorization requests
uh push authorization requests is a
the idea of reducing reliance on the
front channel even further so
in typical oauth you will start the
oauth flow in the front channel by
by sending the user's browser to the
oauth server
instead push authorization requests will
initiate the flow in the back channel by
first having the client go talk to the
os server and it gets back a reference
that it can send the user's browser to
instead
the idea here is just reduce reliance on
the front channel because the front
channel is
is
always it's always possible to attack it
in various ways so this prevents that
completely by not putting any of the
requested in the front channel
there's um
another attempt at securing the
authorization request using a json web
token this one is also um
it it does use the front channel but it
uses it it creates the request in a json
web token so that it can be signed and
then it can't be tampered with which is
a different solution to the same problem
so that one is um that one i believe is
farther along than push authorization
requests but i do expect both of these
to to make their way through the process
and the last thing i want to talk about
is future future oauth you may have
heard rumblings of oauth 3. is there a
no off 3
turns out
there is not an oauth 3 not right now
uh there has have been some efforts to
do things in a what could be called
oauth3 way
there is an effort
called transactional author
xyz which has since been renamed and
that work is now happening in a new
working group in the ietf called the
grant negotiation and authorization
protocol this is a new working group
it's not the same as the old working
group it's different people but there is
some overlap between the two groups and
the idea with this group is to continue
to evolve the the space evolve what is
um
possible
in
this kind of
world of delegated access or or single
sign-on but not relying on not not
relying on the the legacy of oauth of um
not making it backwards compatible not
worrying about about supporting existing
stuff it's more just like what could we
do if we didn't have to
have any backwards compatibility and we
could just start from scratch and and
redesign this whole thing
some of the principles there are back
channel first
uh the idea of the client instance
meaning the a particular install of an
app on a phone or in a browser that is a
first class citizen it's not it's no
longer sort of a concept that's kind of
shoehorned in
and the um asymmetric cryptography or
proof of possession techniques are baked
into the spec and they're not
necessarily extensions
so
network is also very much in progress
it's very early days but uh you can
participate in that if you are curious
about it there's um all these links are
on on oauth.net
and uh with that i want to leave you
with some
places to go for further reading further
research on this so that you can
continue your journey through the world
of oauth um if you're curious about
looking at the oauth uh flows the
authorization code flow pixi open openid
connect the oauth playground is a great
way to try these things out this this
will
walk you through a simulated flow uh
version of all these flows where you can
see the requests and responses in detail
so you can try this stuff out and see
how it works without writing any code
i also have a course a video course
available it's at this url and this is a
there's a lot of content in here that
goes into a lot of the concepts in oauth
in great detail
and it's about three and a half hours of
video content
i also have a book
oauth2simplified.com uh you can also
find the cat stickers at that link as
well
and uh the book is also a a in-depth
guide to the world of oauth the book is
actually also available online if you
just want to read it as a website you
can go to oauth.com and the full
contents of the book are available there
and with that
thank you very much thanks for having me
i hope this was we learned something
today and i'm happy to answer a few
questions looks like we have just enough
time for some questions
thanks aaron that was really thorough
can you uh so then the
could you repeat the um url it's an easy
one to mention the one for the book
fell for the training materials
the
uh you'll find everything at oauth2
oauth2simplified.com
so that links out to the book as well as
the video course is linked down at the
bottom as well
okay fantastic um thanks we these
i'm afraid we're out of time there is a
couple of questions from christian
ruback in the um main stage i'm
wondering if after you get off this
stage if you could have a look at those
chats and um respond to him there
absolutely be happy to okay wonderful
thanks very much um and i invite you to
leave the stage now